[موسيقى]
البحر الاسود والسيناريو الصراع عليه وفيه
قد يكون بابا مفتوحا على احتمالات كثيره
الخطوط الحمراء لم تعد مقتصره على الشواطئ
الاوكرانيه
توسعت دائره الخطر فما الذي يجري في البحر
الاسود صباح الجمعه تعلن وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ان القوات الاوكرانيه حاولت
مهاجمه ميناء نوفروسيسك في البحر الاسود
باستخدام زورقين مسيرين وتضيف الوزاره ان
السفن الروسيه التي تعمل على حراسه
الميناء دمرت الزورقين يلي ذلك تصريح
نقلته وكاله رايترز ونسبته لمصدر امني
اوكراني مفاده ان جهاز الامن الاوكراني
نفذ بالاشتراك مع القوات البحريه
الاوكرانيه عمليه في خليج نوفروسيسك
الروسي وبحسب المصدر نفذت العمليه بزورق
مسير يحمل ونصف طن من المتفجرات استهدف
سفينه انزال روسيه في وقت اكتفى المتحدث
باسم المخابرات الاوكرانيه بتاكيد الهجوم
دون تبنيه
في موسكو هناك اجسام طائره مجهوله الهويه
وهنا الان توجد مسيرات مجهوله الهويه
الحقت اضرارا بسفينه الانزال هذه على
المستوى الامني هذه خساره كبيره لاسطول
المحتلين بخسارتهم سفينه كبيره
بينما نفى المتحدث باسم البحريه
الاوكرانيه طلوع قواته بالاستهداف لسنا
منخرطين في الحاق اي ضرر بهذه السفينه في
البحر الاسود واوكرانيا لا تستهدف اي سفن
مدنيه او اي موانئ مدنيه حتى لو كانت تحت
الاحتلال
ونقلت محطه سي ان ان الامريكيه عن مصدر
اوكراني قوله ان 100 جندي روسي كانوا على
متن السفينه التي اصيبت باضرار وخرجت عن
الخدمه الهجوم بذاته بصرف النظر عن دقه
الروايتين له دلالات كبيره الميناء
المستهدف هو اكبر ميناء في البلاد يحتوي
على اطول خط رسو يتجاوز طوله ثمانيه كيلو
مترات ويحتل موقعا استراتيجيا باعتباره
مفترق طرق النقل الدوليه بين روسيا والبحر
الابيض المتوسط ومناطق في اسيا والسفينه
المنخرطه في الحدث هي اوليني جورسكي
غورنياك دخلت الخدمه عام 67
واعتبرت افضل سفن الانزال في الاسطول
الشمالي الروسي خضعت لعمليات اصلاح وتحديث
انتهت عام 2019
وعدت للخدمه بدايه العام الماضي